i have three audiences that i really can
serve with what i do i have
organizational leaders i have frontline
leaders and i have entrepreneurs
how
do i
serve them all your goal is not to have
a million subscribers or million
followers
your goals have the right followers and
the right subscribers the people who
care about leadership content i've been
around forever the gray hair proves it
has been around for a while if i have no
hair does that mean i've been around for
longer or what
there she is
erica lena in the house how are we doing
doing pretty good a little nervous i'll
be honest i've never done instagram live
before oh my goodness it's happening
eric is doing her first instagram live
this is amazing well what what a time to
do it i mean erica is part of move for
makers and as part of that we do an
instagram live together so
uh you got it all set up it's working
with what what's what's on your mind how
can i help how can i give some
perspective where are we at well i am at
the very beginning of this journey of
doing things on social media i mean i've
been around forever the gray hair proves
it i've been around for a while if i
have no hair does that mean i've been
around for longer or what
i don't know hey let's let some of it
grow back and let's see if you have any
gifts like this
i love it i love it
yeah so i'm really starting to engage
with this and i want to thank you for
that because
having the scheduled and being part of
movement makers is really pulling me out
of my
perfectionist shell that has had me
stuck
and i'm a little terrified but i'm going
for it i'm moving
through it i do have some questions so
i've started this journey i've put some
videos on our post on instagram
and
i posted them because i knew that we
would be here today and then i looked at
your instagram live
is there something that happens with
pressure so having this very hard
deadline
enabled me to get things done
however i'm very critical of what i did
and so i looked at what i did and then i
looked at yours and then i started
comparing and
how
what is your process or what do you how
do you get your
post to look so engaging with video
that's a simple question that i have and
then when i find my other ones i will
ask you those as well
great what a start i love it and listen
i love that you started i mean that the
biggest thing missing is just momentum
and and you've got a huge track record
and a giant heart and it's just getting
the content up so i'm glad that this
session prompted the pressure to go and
actually make the content so that we're
going live like erica i don't see any
content what are you doing
[Laughter]
so that's great being critical is
amazing just not being so critical that
nothing happens
right like
you need to balance being your own worst
critic with also your biggest
cheerleader so you know the fact that
you did it is like
let's go we're doing it we're making
content you're here on instagram live
it's amazing um in looking at the videos
a couple things come to mind the first
is
your um well the website doesn't work so
that's a good starting point which one
so if you go to your instagram bio
uh i'm like oh
d-lane
and you click on the link it it doesn't
work so that's um that's a good starting
point
whether that's you or your your tech
people or whoever
well
it's probably me but i don't even
remember what link i have in the bio i
forgot all about the bio
i've had instagram forever
good but until yesterday i hadn't posted
since covid started so this is how we
gain customers right i mean the idea is
people watch your content and then they
want they click who is this person all
about i've never seen her before and
then they click on your website to learn
more and we want to lead them to
you know a page that works so for now it
goes to
talentinspired.net so if that is still
the website or
no not like so oh it's advertised
but we could change it so that's great
you know we can change that whenever we
want so that that's a good step one
because that's all that's honestly like
if anybody does like you and they watch
the video it's like oh that's
interesting that's their next step is
okay what's her website right um so yeah
that's an easy fix for the videos
themselves and i took a you know quick
peek i haven't watched all of them the
the biggest thing that i would focus on
for you is
what is the
powerful opinion that you have
on a topic
and and i don't know we've talked about
this before but like what do you believe
that other people don't believe and then
that being the first thing if you talk
about making engaging content especially
in an instagram environment the first 10
seconds
it becomes everything
you know you're trying to stop the
scroll
so people are scrolling through and then
oh you pop up i've never seen you before
and if you don't see something like in
the first 10 seconds the first five
seconds
i'm i'm just scrolling i'm going to the
next thing
so
some of your posts you're kind of
hedging at the beginning
and so you're saying things like well i
don't know about you but for me that and
then they're gone
[Laughter]
what do you believe that other people
don't believe that
can be the first sentence
out of your mouth because you have a lot
of
experience and you have a lot of
opinions and you have a lot of knowledge
that can actually help a lot of people
but if if it takes
like 20 seconds to get out then
it's not going to be as engaging
i wouldn't over stress about
that yet
but that's the next step like the first
step is you did it you posted five
videos this is amazing this is great now
in our next five videos that could be
the thing that we focus on is the very
first sentence is something that's going
to be
something that will make people want to
watch the rest of the video like what
did you just say
huh that's interesting and they want to
keep watching
okay i can i can definitely do that
maybe i'll just go five videos at a time
that that'll be my
be my way to go as we just mentioned
there's five videos that i i did and i
started to feel bad because even though
i haven't posted since
the beginning of covet
i was thinking are people getting
bombarded with every single post that
i'm
that because i did them right after
another
is that what sort of frequency would you
recommend as i get things going yeah so
uh people are not getting bombarded by
your posts you know like the algorithm
especially right now
you know like and we're honestly not
we're not that important you know
i could ask that question on youtube as
well it's like how often is like am i
bombarding people like the average
person subscribed to like hundreds of
different channels
you're not that important you know so
use it as a
that's a good thing um what i would say
though is if you're going to make five
batching the content is great five at a
time is great because especially at the
beginning
it can be a little nerve-wracking that
you gotta set up the camera you gotta
you gotta
get it together you know just
emotionally and be ready to be in
presenter mode and the time it takes to
to do one video you can then usually do
four videos right afterwards because
you're already in the same energy and
the same lighting and all that stuff
right so just easier to batch them
together
then i would release them
one a day
okay so if you're gonna be doing five
yoga wednesday afternoon you're gonna
make videos
wink wink you know it's wednesday
afternoon
yeah
let's go erica but you know whenever in
your calendar makes sense
and then you release them
one a day or one every two days
so that they they're they're dripping
out so it's not all five at a time it's
less about bombarding people and more
about
the
instagram just won't show them as much
if you put five out all at the same time
and that's usually the same for every
platform youtube tick tock whatever
if you have five videos you release them
over time got it well um
to go to something not quite so focused
on instagram posting
a question i have
is
i have i have three audiences that i
really can serve with what i do
i have organizational leaders i have
frontline leaders and i have
entrepreneurs
how
do i
serve them all how can i serve them all
um i don't know if it's possible i don't
know if i need to have different
channels i'm a little confused about
that because i can i successfully market
to them now
but it's more one-to-one i network i get
a lot of referrals
but doing it through social media is
something
new for me what what are your thoughts
on that the common theme is still
leadership so the common thing is
leadership yeah so you're talking about
leadership so entrepreneurs are a weird
bunch in that
leadership content actually doesn't do
very well
for most entrepreneurs because most
entrepreneurs
are solo entrepreneurs like most
entrepreneurs don't have a leadership
problem they may have a self leadership
problem because they don't know how to
like stick to a schedule and get up and
go do the work and and
stay consistent so it's more self
leadership but
any time i make content around
leadership or or hr or hiring or
managing it just doesn't do well because
most entrepreneurs aren't in that
position where they even have anybody on
their team and so they're not thinking
about those kinds of problems
and that's fine like those entrepreneurs
aren't the ones that are hiring you yeah
to help them because they can't if they
can't afford to have even a part-time
employee on their staff they're not
hiring you to come and help them right
so it's fine so we're we're not really
it's like a higher level entrepreneur or
maybe business owner that has
x number of employees like at what point
does somebody come in
how big a company do they have to have
or when you start working with the
entrepreneurs typically around 25
employees so i don't know what
percentage of entre you know like
american businesses have to
it's it's a small small small number
yeah most people never get the 25
employees so it's it's entrepreneurs but
really it's it's it's business owners
you know like the people who already
have so you're talking to those people
your goal is not to have a million
subscribers or million followers
your goals have the right followers and
the right subscribers the people who
care about leadership content
now the the you know if there's a
business owner that has 50 employees
and
or there's a manager at a at a
corporation
that might be responsible for 50 people
underneath them it's
similar content
you know the problems they're facing are
similar they may have different
levels of what they can control right
like the entrepreneur owner can do
whatever they want they can implement a
new policy as soon as they want a
manager
at
facebook has a hard time because there's
layers of bureaucracy above them
but a lot of the leadership struggles
and challenges will be
similar and so that's
who we're talking to so all the even
though you might have like three
different audiences it's still the main
theme of leadership
and
we want you to be known as the
leadership person
all right that gives me something to
think about when you mentioned that my
audience may not be as large as others i
think that is something to be
for me to be very aware of and it's uh i
think that's going to be a big takeaway
for me
um
because i think when i think of social
media i'm thinking
it's got to be this huge following where
in my case it may not make sense and
there's something i need to be okay with
something to accept
so i i appreciate that thank you well
it's like what are your what are your
goals you know what are your ambitions
do you want to be
do you want to be an influencer and have
a million followers or do you want to
grow your leadership practice
and
and you tell me because if you want to
be
the face for america for something then
we have to go way downstream and talk to
more startups
and and wannabes and considering
people who will never hire you but
they're at the
very beginning because most people are
at step zero like they're just getting
started i think that's something i've
been kind of struggling with and
in terms of who should i serve so right
now as i mentioned got the people that
have a minimum of 25 employees up to 10
000 employees and they're already a
clientele for that group it's all it's
been a matter of me to continue to
establish some sort of thought
leadership
however
what i
get excited about and passionate about
is helping people that are at the
beginning that want to build something
bigger than what they are so it's not
necessarily the person starting a
business to
to
be a solopreneur
i'm interested in helping those
individuals that are
are building something bigger how big it
is who knows but those individuals that
will need to think about culture one day
those individuals that when they are
hiring their
first second third fourth fifth employee
they know how to do that in such a way
that there is
um integrity within
their within their structure to help
them learn how to stretch and grow and
in many ways get out of their own way
because that's what happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs we get in our own way and
so things just don't grow
and
i have because i've worked with
companies that have
these are small companies 20
in the grand scheme of things 25
employees if you compare that to a
company that has 10 10 000
you know those are some smaller
companies i work with but they had to go
through some changes they had some
growth to get to that point so i want to
work with those i'm excited to work with
those people that are at the beginning
a fantasy of mine would be to be
connected with the different incubators
all around the world startups and
connecting and talking to them more
about
this beginning piece helping them truly
understand themselves
deeply
and better because things are going to
grow from
from there so i would think of it as
three different buckets and there's
different size of buckets and
there's no right or wrong it's really
more like what what's the right for you
that you want to go and chase down right
so the the smallest
size bucket with the highest revenue
bucket immediately is is the people who
you're already serving right like 25
employees to 10 000 employees you
already have a business model that works
they will pay you you you make a lot of
money doing it they're ideal clients
making content
on social for people who are searching
that's like you make one deal
from that that ends up paying for
everything right it just that's a
no-brainer kind of starting point
that's the
big big revenue bucket immediate
business model but super small clientele
the next stage would be the people who
are at the beginning of their hiring
journey and they're starting to think
about hiring and culture and training
and leadership and it's like just
starting to come on their radar
whether that's through videos whether
that's through incubators whether that's
like they're they're going and they're
searching how do i be a better boss you
know like they hired somebody like
everybody goes to that they hire
somebody he's like this person is going
to solve all my problems and then that
person quits because you don't know how
to lead them and then you're back to
writing like maybe i'll just do it all
myself instead like all of those
problems and starting up right
so then it's like what's the business
model that's gonna be attached to it and
maybe we don't care maybe you're just
building a brand maybe you're just
trying to get the message out there i'm
always concerned that i want to make
sure that you're making not just you but
anybody like you're making money in the
process so that it's not just this hobby
on the side so your priority for this
year is like i want this to generate
revenue for me then we're targeting 25
employee plus people we know we have a
business model for
if it's i'm building my brand and i'm
going to do something at scale i'm going
to do group coaching i'm going to i'm
going to have my book or my course or i
want to i want to be a speaker or like
we're building the erica brand
then
the payoff revenue wise is longer
because it's nothing direct right now
but we're building towards something
that is exciting for you that for the
next five years that decade we're going
to be building right
cool that's that's like the the and that
leads to tons of opportunities like
maybe you get maybe you get asked to
join the board of some of these
incubators and you're taking a piece of
every company that goes like there's so
many opportunities that then open
themselves up to you and it it can
create a
a longer term bigger model than just
time for for money as a consultant
right yes i definitely want to step out
of the time for money business model and
it's great to have like both
so you you're making money doing your
service cool and you're building this
thing because if if you stop being a
consultant then you have no money coming
in it's like well that's a problem right
so
doing both is great the third bucket is
the biggest bucket which then is self
leadership
which i don't know if you even want to
dive into or not
because that's where most people are at
they're not thinking culture and
teamwork and leadership and like that's
not even on the radar for most people
but self-leadership definitely is
and so if you wanted to be like broad
that's where you go after you can have a
million subscriber channel and and try
to go big
and that could still lead to book deals
and courses and speaking and board seats
and everything else it's just more of a
personal choice like how much of your
passion connects to self-leadership
versus
leading teams of people
well you you say that and one of the
stories i think about um
is when my daughter was a little girl we
were in church this it feels like a
gazillion years ago
and
i
i was just sitting there
i was just sitting just sitting there on
the church pew probably trying to stay
awake who knows what i was trying to do
and i finally just sit up i straighten
up and then out of the corner of my eye
i noticed my daughter she she did the
same thing
and so the con the the idea that someone
is always watching more leading by
example has something that's always
fascinated me and that could connect to
self leadership
um
yeah that i mean that's a that's a
definite possibility i don't think i've
ever thought of it
i don't think i've ever thought of self
leadership as a topic that i would speak
on because typically i'm working with
people that are trying to move up in
their career they're trying to get a
promotion or maybe there's some sort of
remediation
um
but there is always that connection
between
their job their life
i don't know that's something that's
something i have to think about that
third bucket that's something brand new
you're already doing it you may have
been you may not have been like calling
it that but like if somebody then if
you're coaching somebody and you give
them advice on what they need to do they
still need to go off and and do it and
they need to stay consistent on their
calendar and that's like how does
somebody then
execute the advice that you give them
well that's self leadership
right where how many times that people
say they're going to do something or go
to a conference and get excited and then
not follow through right so like they
have poor self-leadership and so what
whether we want to call it like
motivation or habits or belief systems
or whatever at the end of the day it's
leading yourself to go do the thing
and the more you are
a role model for yourself you become a
role model for other people you know
from sitting up straight into church to
anything to when you show up at the
office
first first and leave a lot you know or
are you the last person to leave all
that um and so that that's definitely a
model but it's more like that's a hard
decision do you
want to be that woman or like no i like
culture teamwork and and my dream is to
help incubators and people who are at
the starting stage of hiring but i don't
want to dive into the personal stuff
yeah that's uh like you said it's a
heart thing and so i am i think i'm
going to have to go in and just kind of
marinate in that and
make it
through
yeah just get in there and marinate in
it and then we'll put put on the
barbecue um so so then from the content
right so it's still it's all leadership
content
so it's
it's the the content for the
organizations and like leading a team of
people
it's a content and leadership of of
getting started and the first things you
need to consider and then potentially
it's like like the one and two you
definitely want to do
so we already know that the third bucket
is a maybe and so if it becomes a yes
and you want to tell stories that then
can bring
even your story there with with your
daughter that's more that's like
parenting but that's still legal well
yeah that's it
but it's still leadership it's all
leadership right so it's like how much
do we want to expand the scope of
leadership because when you do that and
you see that in your daughter you then
take that to your business and your
career and say maybe i can if i could do
that with my daughter maybe i can
influence the people at the board
room table here and i'm going to
sit set up straight or i'm going to have
more energy i'm going to smile more it
all connects it's still all leadership
just how much do you want to play in
that third field or not
yeah well i mean you say that and i i
think
about a time where i was actually
speaking on something i call maternal
leadership the the leadership that
mothers
have
and so i've always gravitated towards
leadership and maternal leadership has
nothing to do with
a big organization or
a career per se like outside of the home
but it embodies all of life and how do
you make it work and so lots to think
about this is
i
um
that's good it's good we're marinating
you're gonna marinate on it we're
marinating i'm like
here's the recommendation then like we
know we want a in one and two and three
is probably something that you'll want
to get into which is the how exactly is
still
got to figure out but if you're going to
make five videos
every every kind of filming day then you
can do two towards the large companies
two towards the startups and one
one fun one towards
churches or motherhood or
self-leadership or
whatever is kinda
whatever comes from the marination
yeah whatever maybe i'll just call it
marinade this is the marinated bucket
but it's still all leadership right like
it's still all leadership and that's the
connective tissue and all of the
all of the
stories that you share in the examples
you give will have ripple effects out to
that person's entire life beyond just
this one scenario that we're solving
i agree i agree
okay and it'll get uh
the the first bucket you have the most
knowledge and most depth and most like
bang on
you'll be the most perfect because you
know that inside out the second one
you're exploring and having fun with and
you've helped a lot of startups and
maybe not as many as like the
corporations and the third one is the
least clear and most
fuzzy foggy whatever and so the content
will be
the work in progress it's like letting
go of the perfection of if i'm making a
video on motherhood leadership it may
not be as good out of the gate as the
one
talking about higher how to hire
somebody and like what questions should
you ask in in you know a job interview
or like the stuff that you'll know how
to do inside out versus
the motherhood one where you may have to
think a lot more because you're working
through it
yeah okay
this is this is good i see that our time
is up that went so fast
time flies when you're having fun
yeah well i'll see you tomorrow in mover
makers
and and uh marinate on those and and
then let me know how
how it's sitting i think there's i think
there's definitely something there and
it's great to have that mix of
i actually know what i'm talking about
here and i'm exploring and playing in
these other areas as well i think it'll
be okay you have an impact on people and
it also will be it'll be fun
it'll be fun all
right oh my goodness there he is
how you doing orlando
not bad yourself i'm great man
so uh orlando's part of movement makers
and as part of that we're doing uh ig
live together so
what's on your mind man how can i help
yeah so literally about a year ago right
i started with um movement makers and uh
you inspired me to get a video out that
day and i did and that's the only video
i got on youtube is that one video
so i think the theme of of this one on
one is uh getting started again
so can i hit read this reset button
uh i have an intern this summer
and what we're doing right now is we're
taking a lot of the interviews that i've
taken or the video already have
so i've done videos and interviews with
different hosts and different shows and
different programs
and that we're going through that and
editing it
for the purpose of publishing it or
repurposing it
um funny enough i saw
your comment recently when you're doing
a live ask me anything and you mentioned
you know
making smaller pieces of that long piece
is not going to do much for you i was
like oh darn
but it's where i'm at right now right so
i have something we can edit we can
start publishing it the idea was taking
that long piece of content publishing on
linkedin and then having smaller pieces
to post on uh formatted correctly and
and and cut well for the consumption on
linkedin facebook instagram and maybe
even tick tock so that's what we're
going to try to do five five different
platforms
go long first and then repurpose for
each of those other platforms in a way
that for example an instagram you know
daily post
you know to get it out there um that's
where i'm at right now that's what we're
doing but um i you can comment on that
if you like to kind of talk about where
i'm at
and what's your thoughts on that but i i
also like in this call to cover um some
practical things kind of getting started
again of like okay let's just do step
one step two step three break it down
for me again and say look ideally about
where you were land though this is how i
want you to take action this is the
first thing through whatever step five
whatever it is
and go like more of a approach thing
cool so
to start
cutting up the videos for micro content
to the to the other platforms is great
okay for youtube not so much you can do
it for youtube shorts which is a
relatively new feature so you can do
that but for for
you know youtube loves long form video
so it won't work as well for regular
youtube content but definitely cutting
it up for the other platforms makes a
ton of sense with by the way since i had
no
lead magnet or anything else the call to
action would be simply to bolster the
youtube channel and have people watch
the full
version of it in the youtube channel
that's the best thing i can come up with
right now since i don't have more
content or a lead magnet
great so you use it for now you know i
mean the i l i love for now stuff
right like because otherwise if you
never do for now then you get stuck of
going another year without making
content right right so for now it's fine
just
it's for now and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna get better we're gonna keep
so having a lead magnet will be
important for the business right and
that's ultimately we're gonna drive
people to
um but for now yeah momentum like that's
what's really missing
so what
to give you like a practical plan you
can stick to
what prevented you
from making more content in the past
year
yeah there's um
at every stage of getting something out
the door i was stuck so for example on
the theme of what to talk about there
was that problem and some of the quick
answers is hey throughout the day
someone asked me a question
uh then take that and just make an
answer and put it out
problem is if i'm looking for an ideal
10 minutes or more in content for again
starting with youtube first and then
repurposing out
um
it just takes a little bit more work in
my mind with
okay how do i fill that up because i
like to give succinct answers obviously
it's a real person who doesn't want to
sit there for 10 minutes with one
question
then i got to go through the formula
then then again the next thing right
happens okay so what's the formula let
me break it down let me come up with my
um my my shocking kind of statement my
my hey let me stop you the tracks
thought uh thought leader lead and then
go through and fill out each of those it
just
it was like pretty hard i think for me
um the next thing is i was thinking okay
well
in order to do that maybe i need to do
some research and i go down the rabbit
hole like okay maybe some data maybe
some you know it's like then done and
nothing happens so what's missing is the
for now
okay right so just do a two minute
answer put it up or whatever it lands
yeah okay like a two-minute answer uh
you know once a week is better than
nothing for a year
yeah
so this is our for now because like
anything else the as you get more
practice as you get more into it it
becomes easier and and then you're ready
to take the next step
if you're trying to learn like if you're
trying to learn english you start with
some common words and some basic you
know grammar structure because if you
through them the entire dictionary to
remember they're not going to get it
it's just too difficult right so you
layer things on as you go so worrying
about the perfect research topic or
having the powerful opinion and all like
that's
it becomes overwhelming
i know you don't do anything and this
isn't just orlando this is everybody so
so it's fine so it's creating the same
mindset of for now like you're doing on
the other platforms
because if you haven't posted here's a
concern if you haven't posted in a year
i'm less concerned about like reigniting
the audience or what are people going to
think like forget about that it's just
more
if you haven't posted in a year and now
you're trying to post to all the
platforms
that could be
a huge trap because it becomes
overwhelming to have to post
everywhere and maintain that system
right
so uh if you have somebody helping you
amazing but the most important thing is
we need to get some consistent content
going out you were doing business
brokering yep yep so i'm a business so
aspira is the brand and we have a
business brokerage buying and selling
privately held businesses 20 million
below so we do main street low middle
market kind of m a or intermediary work
and we also have the real estate
brokerage uh which um the broker of
record
uh on that company which is a separate
uh company under the brand and uh that's
commercial residential mostly investment
stuff and of course they complement each
other because a lot of business owners
also own the real estate they need
advice on you know all that kind of
stuff
and then the third is advisory that's
you know partly personally investing and
having an investment partner sign up
whatever lps you you know just
there's or fee um fee services including
uh what's the valuation of the business
okay here's a fee for
telling you what your most probable
sales prices of your business in today's
market things like that so those are
three major
divisions of a spirit
so if somebody's trying to sell their
business
i mean you've done it so many times but
for a lot of people it's their first
time
they they they have a lot of questions
before they just sign up with you and go
through the process right
yep
so what's a common question that they
would ask
yeah so if i could take that what you're
saying and take it as a theme
so i think as a whole bracket of
questions you're first saying look come
up with things that will help with the
flow of my business so onboarding a
business owner first of all even
answering prospects questions or
frequently asked questions and then
maybe even ask another category of um
should ask questions anything they even
think about asking that that kind of
lead into that
and then even with buyers right so
buyers looking at businesses for sale we
we you know of course respond to them
that might be another category you're
coming up with a whole bunch of video
ideas now for your channel right yeah
i'm trying to think big picture more
systemically so i can just kind of like
break it down and just get to it um
but yeah so you know in terms of the
business owners looking to sell their
business
you know the three major categories
again just kind of high level is you
know is my business sellable
um how much can my business sell for and
what's the process look like so every
time i consult with a person who's
looking to sell their business that's
how i set the agenda for the call i said
there's anything else they say nope that
covers everything i need to know and we
just jump right in okay so if somebody's
going to come into your office and say
hey first off you already have now these
are all video topics so your whole like
researching what do you that's what you
talk about
is my business sellable
how long does the process take how much
can i get from my business these are all
videos where are people going to learn
how to do this yeah
right they're like there's nobody
they're gonna learn from you they're
gonna learn from your videos
so if you take a question like that so
now we already have a list of ideas that
you can make content on like those are
the easiest kinds of videos to make
because you answer those questions day
in day out
helping people yep somebody comes into
your office and says hey orlando is my
business sellable
are you just going to give a two-minute
answer for them and then say thank you
and kick them out
uh actually on that portion without the
questions i have asked i have to ask
them
i i try to keep their two three minutes
to give them really in a nice little
succinct
hey you know this is what you need to
understand about making a business
sellable so if you own your business
and i can go through those two three
minutes with you but you know i do i
stop there and then i you know i i can
you know and then i have some questions
for that but i can of course cover those
questions leave those as perhaps some
some food for thought for anybody who's
watching the video
and i guess i could put a third
component to that um
i need your help here can get a little
stuck but a third component to make it
go to 10 minutes or so whatever eight
minutes or six minutes i'm guessing i
could probably add in there um
you know
something about them being prepared for
a call and just having this information
what you need
um but that's probably about it i'm
thinking right now in terms of how to
get that bigger but that's so help me
through this i'm stuck on that yeah
again so first off like
for now if it's a two minute video or
five minute video go like that's it for
now let's get it going
um to make it longer just imagine what
happens when somebody's coming into your
office and wants to sell their business
and doesn't know if if they if they're
big enough how much how much of the fees
how like they just don't know the
process they've never done it before
that meeting is going to last a total of
how long
with you
uh to cover those three items uh with
the back and forth roughly 20 minutes or
so so they're going to come in they're
going to talk for 20 minutes and they're
going to leave your office no most of
the uh consults are by phone like
somebody's going to call you that call
you've never you've never met them
before
you're going to they're going to say hey
i want to sell my business orlando i
don't know the process
that call lasts 20 minutes typically
uh yeah i mean it can go of course
longer we're going to the next step and
we're going further but
but yeah
so
that's what that's what the video
becomes like it doesn't mean the video
has to be 20 minutes but
you say something well that's that's
only because you're answering questions
and it usually takes longer for them to
answer questions than it is for me to
kind of get my part yeah like it's the
same call
every time pretty much right like
there's some mind there's just some
minor differences but you know what
they're going to ask when they call you
that's the same eight questions they
lead with and then it's the same 20
questions afterwards that you just know
how to answer because it keeps coming up
over and over so when somebody's on a
call with you
you give them the space to ask the
question that you know they're going to
ask anyway right like they pick pick
from this bag of questions you know
they're going to ask it but you give
them the space to ask it in a video
where it's just one way
there's no space for them to ask a
question
right i mean they can leave a comment
and you ask but
what you want to do
is
answer the next questions for them
because you already know what their
follow-up questions are going to be
so you take the question you take the
video further down the path by answering
their next question so you can still
keep it to two minutes three minutes
okay so is my business sellable well
here's what you have to think about
three-minute answer done now you may be
asking
whatever the next question is right
so you already know what they're going
to ask next just bring that into the
video as if you're having a conversation
but you have to bring the questions
because there's no way to interact with
you while you're recording
yeah
it doesn't mean you have to go all the
way to 20 minutes or half an hour if
they're with you 45 minutes or whatever
but
imagine doing the role play okay you've
just said this stuff and this is easier
for you because you've already had all
these conversations not like you have to
imagine a fictitious conversation you're
already having this all the time when
people come
and call your office
so just take the conversation further
and and play both sides so you may be
asking
well how do i know if it's the right fit
for me
and then you may be asking well how much
does this cost and how long does it take
it's like all of the questions that
people will ask you each time that's how
you can make the video longer and and
not just longer because of youtube
algorithm but like more value to
like if you just answer the question in
three minutes and then shut it down
they're left with maybe more questions
than answers like okay but what about
this this this and this
right
answer those questions for them on the
video
yeah
which by the way is another thing i'm
getting mired into a little bit is um
using the smaller pieces to create
bingeable content to stop those
algorithms
so is that is that even correct where
basically if you can get through a
minute or two minutes or three minutes
of something it says to answer the next
question or whatever to cover that topic
and i have a little card click the next
one and watch the next two three minute
video
and is that would that help as a
strategy to do it that way where they
kind of watch a second video of mine uh
on youtube it definitely works i would
just try to make every video
longer
again for now you go and you make it
but then try to make those ten minute
videos instead of three minute videos
the other way around it is to tell a
story and stories
stories sell and stories also help make
it more um
it helps pass the understanding on
makes it easier for people to consume
and digest
so if somebody comes and asks you hey
how do i sell my business you can go
give your three-minute answer
and then say for example i had i had
somebody come in and you can change you
don't say the person's name or the
industry or the name of the company or
or whatever or you could
do a hypothetical like so for example
you know if you're a restaurant and
you're trying to sell your business
and then you explain it through the
example of the restaurant
yeah i like that that's great
have a store in our example for
everything that you're sharing like when
you have somebody in front of you
you're probably already doing this
anyway through their business if
somebody comes you and they have an auto
dealership like hey orlando help me sell
my auto dealership you're gonna tell the
story through the lens of an auto
dealership
just naturally because you're not going
to tell some story of a
of a bakery or something right it's it's
an auto dealership but when somebody's
watching a video again you have no idea
what industry they're in
so be able to give an example
for a lot of people it's it's their
first time and it's confusing and
overwhelming they don't know what to do
next so giving them an example can help
so okay so let's say you're a bakery and
you're trying to sell your bake shop
here's what here's what we would need to
know
and so you can now emphasize the points
and explain the points that you just
made in the three first three minutes
through the use of an example of a real
client or a fake client or made up
client would you recommend um
let's say that first video we're talking
about here it's it's however long we
have stories in there so it's looking
good and it's really engaging um having
those time stamps
in the description so that they can go
okay
0.1 and then story example 4.1 and then
like break it down like that is that
helpful
so i'll take this answer in like two
ways
one way to answer the question is no i
haven't we've done a whole bunch of
testing and haven't proven that it works
a lot of people use it as a best
practice but i haven't seen any data
that show that it leads to more
retention on the video in fact often it
leads to less retention because people
skip ahead to the next thing um
so i wouldn't i'm not recommending it
and i'm not doing it um
but the second path of that question is
like dude it doesn't matter make videos
right like all of the questions that are
basically getting in the way of making
content of having a perfect structure
and format and how youtube works when
when nothing is going up so that's the
like it's it's good for now and keep
creating keep posting keep making and
then you take it through your three
sides of the business right if the third
one i think you said was business
valuations how much is my business worth
advisory yeah
yeah so you're not gonna sell it but
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
evaluate their business yeah it's mostly
investment advisory uh as well as just
the fee based stuff yeah so investment
advisory includes like investing
together so maybe putting content out
there you're talking about working
together on investment opportunities
yeah so how to find the right
opportunity
what factors what are the main factors
to look at you have a you have a process
you have your methodology it may not be
like fully written out or maybe it is
but you have you have the certain
questions that you ask
when you're looking at making investment
so like that's another video and then
make an example so for example if i was
looking at buying a software company
here's what i want to look at
right
and then maybe you throw a second
example because the software company
might have a higher valuation have a
higher multiple because they're more
profitable than a bakery
so for example then if i but if i wanted
to buy bakery it'd be looking at these
and so in like making
making the examples happen it makes it a
lot more clear for people watching and
also
extends the video
so so you sparked another idea which is
to do industry specific videos
so
do kind of a similar thing but really
talk about
uh florist
talk about bakers like you said you know
talk about auto body shops talk about
pizzerias
as a business and then basically make a
video talking about that so pizzeria
owners this is what you're dealing with
i understand kova did this to you you're
doing really well but you have to
understand you know all that is just
really giving give the business owners
um
advice
to that particular market so getting
niched down in content i guess is that
that's the idea that i kind of walked
away with that one
the last comment was more if it's a more
broad one that to give a couple examples
because if you're doing if you're doing
multiple of earnings however you're
evaluating the business
a software company should look
dramatically different than a bake shop
right for how much the company's gonna
be worth and what multiple we're taking
so if you're gonna give a general like
how much is my business worth
you can talk for a couple minutes on it
but then it also depends on the industry
that you're in where then you can give a
couple examples so that's a video if you
wanted to do industry specific videos
how do i evaluate a pizza shop how do i
evaluate a bake shop how do i evaluate a
car dealer yeah those could all work too
those i would try to find i would i
would make videos around the companies
that you actually want to invest in like
if you have no interest in buying pizza
shops then don't make pizza videos
if you love software companies then make
videos about because then we start
attracting the right people in
because ultimately your goal is not to
be a huge youtuber or influencer like we
need more business coming in
right you're trying to get deal flow
yeah
which is for which is fine which is fair
so like let's optimize for that
yeah although um i think you know
one thing i realized is you have to be
intentional about what we're doing and
visualizing where the end looks like and
and try it helps to kind of pull you in
the right direction and so
i was telling you my intern today we
were just meeting and i mentioned that
look i
let's activate the intention of doing
the best things we can do to get to 2
million subscribers on a youtube channel
but give us the break and and no stress
pressure knowing that we're starting
from someplace
and then in video 10 or 5050 when i look
back at video one and be embarrassed by
it which is you know some things you
mentioned many times but i i was
thinking that uh at least i was
motivated today about look let's make
that effort as if okay
and and that just ups the standard in
terms of where we're going and hopefully
accelerates our iterative iterative
learning that was my uh my thought for
today
yeah i honestly wouldn't worry about
upping the standard yet right again like
there's nothing on there so we don't
worry there's nothing so what are we
raising the standard on right like so
iterative yes right so like okay we made
our first video it's two minutes now
let's make it better for the next one
and yeah for sure
um but i think the ultimate goal would
be to how can we how can we use youtube
to grow your business and get more leads
coming in and just educate people a lot
more and what it takes to
build a valuable company that then you
can sell and what your options are
afterwards whether they end up hiring
you or not but we're putting out you
know like that's a that's an important
topic
it's probably not a two million
subscriber channel like if you're gonna
go
you want to hit 20 subscribers now we
got to dive more into mindset and habits
and routines and
more like hidden all of america
which maybe becomes an ambition but
you've got a real opportunity and
expertise inside of what you do
and people aren't making enough content
on it that you can provide a real value
to to
business owners and also help grow your
company at the same time
yeah
so i would just think like what are the
what are the questions people ask you
consistently
answer that question and then tell even
that's your basic it's like it's you're
giving to give your statement and tell
the story
and that's it for now don't worry about
like all the the perfect format and
template and
lead magnet and we'll get there
right for now
yeah yeah for now is like the theme of
this call for now we're doing it for now
it's a you're teaching me something and
then you tell me a story about it
and that becomes a content that you put
out consistently that then you can bring
to the other platforms as well
yeah
so just just basically for now try to
get to 50 or 100 video posts and
content and then figure out from there
what to do with it
there's a lot you could do with it
afterwards right but like we just don't
have enough orlando content to do
anything with
yeah
so all of those could win hard on
linkedin like linkedin should be huge
for you
yeah
for getting business tick tock maybe i
mean tick tock i wouldn't concern myself
with as much
but linkedin for sure even twitter could
be a good spot for you
and the same video you could post like
you just make it 45 seconds and then you
post to twitter you post the linkedin
you know take take little clips
um
but it's just getting orlando in front
of a camera and press record
and do do 10 at a time like you just sit
there in your chair and you just make 10
videos
because the energy it takes to like make
one video you can then go and make five
more right after right
right
okay and in terms of i mean everything
else i imagine i already know the answer
in terms of those steps step one is
uh coming with some topics to to record
content we covered that
and then the rest really doesn't matter
i guess the answer is it really doesn't
matter just
record it doesn't matter about how you
break it down doesn't matter how long it
is does it doesn't matter about editing
it just publish it if you know just get
it out there
yeah honestly the editing and the the
steps
uh
matter even less because
you know what you're doing like you know
if you didn't know the answer to those
questions then that's a big problem
right if somebody walks in if the video
is about how do you evaluate your
business and you don't know how to
evaluate a business
that's a big problem
like i can't i mean i can't help you
with that one you have to know your
industry
but that's why people are watching
they're not watching you because you
have fancy editing and lower thirds and
music and b-roll of somebody climbing up
a mountain and
you know like that's not why those those
work but that's not why i'm watching
your video
you have knowledge it's getting out of
here and in into the world um and people
will watch that because they want to
learn so
i wouldn't be so concerned about how
many steps are in each video
um because just talk like you would not
imagine someone's in front of you and
has that question just talk to them like
you would talk to them
you know the other problem that i have
in my head is um i just feel like i
don't want to listen to myself like i i
that's just what's in my head like i
don't know if i want to listen to that
so i get stuck with like okay is that
even worth you know publishing and then
listen after this call you know
the last call was uh just get that one
video out right this call you're asking
me to do is look just produce produce
i'll produce and i'll put it out there
but i'm gonna i know i'm gonna have the
feeling that it's all like stuff that i
wouldn't even spend 20 minutes listening
to like for 10 minutes
but it's true you wouldn't
i don't want to spend 20 minutes
watching myself either
but you already know this stuff like
here's the thing people call you and
they want to spend 20 minutes talking to
you
you're not making a video for you you're
making a video for your your your
audience your customers like i don't
want to hear myself talk
so don't don't let that be the um
how you judge it
yeah
you should not want to watch it right
like this is this is it's stuff you
already know you're not learning
anything you're not learning anything
but you're teaching i mean i'll take
that to answer my other problem which is
you know i i look at it and so that
wasn't quite well succinct i was a
little you know just talking too much
about it because it's like okay you're
boring like just if you get the subject
matter the way you delivered it but
that's just a matter of just practice
that's a matter of looking at it again
okay now i have a better angle of coming
at it and just you know just go so that
answers that question as well the answer
to everything is for now for now just
just yeah
it's boring for now like maybe it is
boring but even in your boring
it's still valuable
because who else is talking about this
stuff
so it's still useful for people yeah
yeah i really want to make it more
entertaining like there's this guy
called law by mike on tick tock who has
millions of freaking viewers and he's
taking law and making it interesting but
it's crazy production over there it's
about production he's got these
different cuts he is giving himself a
haircut he's the police officer and you
know stopped pulling himself over i mean
it's hilarious there's a lot of
production into it uh so i'm not sure if
tick tock's just a different angle but
but i
i really just want to entertain i really
want to make it
you know
fun and and engaging
so you can but for now we got to get
going it's like it's like an
entrepreneur comes to you and says
orlando i want to i want to sell my
business for 10 million dollars cool
where you at now nothing
you got to get going dude right
like
that's i love it like having inspiration
is fantastic can you work towards
building that 100
and for now
you just got to get going
okay
for now this is it for now this is it
for and and then yes iterate and raise
your standards and keep keep pushing
your intern or your team to do and keep
pushing yourself to do better but not at
the expense of a video not going up
right so like every week a video has to
go up
and then inside of that let's try to
make it better but don't try to make it
so good that then nothing gets created
right
right so at this point i think for my
own self um i gotta remind myself but
i'm not embarrassed and i took too long
to get it out
i gotta just feel embarrassed get it out
go and
and and see what happens
and so is it just for now yeah
in terms of getting you know with with
the topics we talked about you recommend
starting with uh talking to
creating content for the business owners
looking to sell
or it doesn't really matter just
whatever inspires go yeah we're like who
do you want to attract who do you want
to be picking up the phone and calling
you out of your three divisions i mean
it could be all three but who do you
want to call you and then make videos
targeting them so like if you don't want
big shops to call you to sell their
business don't make content around big
shops
i kind of want it all and then if i can
i'm also looking to recruit so i
need to create content around that too i
think
there's a lot of stuff to do i guess
i've just got to get started just you
know
maybe write them all out and then pick
one out of a hat and just go
you don't even i mean we already talked
about like four different ideas plus in
here you think about your three
divisions and you already had it like
they're these questions cool and i'll
just tack a story on the end of each one
how to evaluate my business great teach
me for three minutes and then tell me a
story
next okay
don't worry about the rest of it don't
worry about that intro
about the hook well for now we will we
will but like not at the expense of
videos not going up yeah get those out
for now
and then we'll worry about intro and
worry about length and more about lead
magnet and where and listen after you
worry about that there's more stuff to
worry about too and then even more stuff
to worry about too you're like you're
like the startup entrepreneurs like how
how am i going to raise the venture
capital to hire like the big ceo i want
to hire like the former ceo of disney to
run my company
like dude you haven't started what are
you doing right like we need you need to
get let's get to ten thousand dollars in
revenue first you know but and then a
hundred and then a million and then
right so all of that stuff will matter
and you could be the next doctor whoever
lawyer guy awesome yes
that could happen
but not if you're not making content
right so it's like the basics first and
then you build on those once the basics
become easy
like if you can't come up with video
topics yet and press record nothing else
will matter
so you get the basics down and that
might happen fast maybe you do like a
month of those like wow this is so much
easier than i thought cool now you now
we add in whatever the next level is if
it's lead magnet or longer videos or
better intros or cards at the end or
right if if you had just started a year
ago and kept going we'd be having a
different conversation by now
yeah a much more advanced conversation
right and that's not to like
no yeah
that's just this is where we're at right
but cool so like between now and next
year
that's the difference and then we'll be
having a different conversation and
that's that's amazing and it's beautiful
but it's you getting that
if whether it's like i'm gonna be
embarrassed and just post cool or you
just tell yourself this is it for now
and and then i'm gonna we're gonna get
better and in a month and two months and
three months will be better and not have
the burden of perfection
or the burden of we have to build a 2
million subscriber channel or the burden
of like making it look super
entertaining
yet
right
you can get there
yeah
okay
it's more the same i did it i get it all
right time to make videos orlando thank
you all right thank you again appreciate
you man we'll see you soon
okay take care if you want to see me
coach another entrepreneur check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there school system is a
great place to be but it's nice when you
can apply what you learn and show the
world what you can do kids are some of
the most entrepreneurial people
i know if you experiment you can always
get better that's for sure